so what happens if you are a Democrat
and you don't tow the Democrat line then
they get the operatives out there right
they get the MSNBC hacks to get out
there and destroy you because you as a
Democrat are not good enough for them
here is msnbc's mehdi Hassan going after
RFK Jr and just listen to the way he
talks about this guy under Kennedy to
boot what more
well
actually sadly there's plenty wrong with
Robert F Kennedy Jr and his long-shot
presidential bid here's just three
worrying things among many that you
should know about him first Robert
Kennedy Jr is one of America's leading
anti-vaxxers and conspiracy theorists
second Robert F Kennedy Jr might be
running for the Democratic presidential
nomination and he might be saying a few
left-wing sounding things but he's
backed by former Trump advisor and
far-right organizer Steve Bannon yes
Bannon reports CBS news's Robert Costa
has been encouraging Kennedy to run for
months believing he could be both a
useful Chaos Agent in the 2024 race and
the big name who could help Stoke
anti-vaccine sentiment around the
country forgive me if I don't buy
Kennedy's left-wing credentials and I'm
not surprised that he went on Tucker
Carlson's White Power Hour on Fox to
promote his Democratic presidential bid
lastly RFK Jr may have the support of
Steve Bannon but he doesn't have the
support of his own family of the rest of
the Kennedy Clan yes the man whose real
claim to fame is that he's the third
eldest of the late Bobby Kennedy's 11
kids has been publicly denounced by many
of the other Kennedy kids the people who
know him best forgive me but
abandoned-backed Tucker platformed
anti-vaxxa conspiracy theorist who's
running on his Kennedy name but can't
count on the support of the actual
Kennedys is perhaps not the progressive
or principled or anti-establishment or
liberal Democratic party Champion that
he might want you to think he is there's
just so much dribble there and liberal
by the way Maddie has nothing to do with
Progressive it's the most illiberal
ideology there but just listen to the
way to Bannon backed so the implication
is he's Steve bandin back I'm pretty
sure Steve Bannon is still backing
Donald Trump but Steve Bannon might like
hearing some of the things that RFK has
said about vaccines the other one was
Tucker platform form well yes it's true
Tucker Carlson did let RFK Jr on the
show to talk I know that's very scary
for Democrats because the scariest thing
is that for the average Progressive
might be that a more moderate Democrat
might talk to a moderate Republican or
conservative whatever you want to call
Tucker and then they realize oh my God
we actually have more in common and it's
the hysterics that we're trying to get
rid of and then of course he calls him
an anti-vaxxer which the phrase
anti-vaxxer seven years ago had a
certain meaning now pretty much
everyone's saying is an anti-vaxxer the
covid vaccines did not work the coveted
vaccines caused all sorts of vaccine
injuries thank God I did not get
vaccinated none of my guys got
vaccinated in here how's everyone
feeling today by the way
thank you
everyone at once gave me a thumbs up
everyone's feeling good here
[Music]